je m'attends par en floride avec trois
années et qui ni une est bien de retour
ils ont pensé à tout sauf aux
embouteillages le pire cauchemar des
voyageurs se réalisent alors ils ratent
leur avion enfin arrivent à l'aéroport
il fait le gros prix pour un nouveau
billet d'avion aller seulement
et puis tout est oublié ils se
prélassent sur les plages de floride
pendant une semaine
mais quand il arrive à l'aéroport pour
le retour
c'est un cauchemar 2 comme il n'était
pas inscrit sur le vol allait leur
billet de retour ont été automatiquement
annulés
cette politique est très répandue chez
les transporteurs et si vous manquez une
portion du vol ce qu en anglais on
appelle le dos chaud ce n'est pas
seulement cette portion qui est perdu
c'est votre réservation complète qui
était nul et c'est parfaitement légal
jonathan et ses amis doivent donc
acheter un nouveau billet du retour le
20 mille histoires liées devions sont
comme les jumeaux ils sont inséparables